welcome to our third video guide of
black arts date Alex Grimm strategy RPG
set in the world of the dark I in the
last two installments we gave you an
introduction to the classes and shed
some light on attributes talents and
abilities of your characters and today
we're going to tackle the heavy stuff we
are well enough prepared to join the
fray and talk about the combat system
first things first though this guard
refers to the rules implemented in
version 1.3 of the game if you haven't
downloaded that already you can find the
patch on the game's official site WWWE
when a battle in black art starts the
scene will change and you'll see the
battlefield and your party ready for
action the battle maps are divided into
a number of hex fields your adventurous
and their opponents move across a combat
lock in the upper right part of the
screen gives detailed information about
what happened during the fight the list
of portraits on the lower edge of the
screen shows health Astro points how
experienced your enemies are as well as
any status effects called buffs or
debuffs and the initiative order and
that's already the first important
keyword initiative order initiative
order movement and actions no matter a
friend or foe each character has an own
initiative value determining when it is
time to act whoever has the highest
initiative goes first but there's a
twist each character rolls a d6 and adds
the result to their initiative score so
there are days when even the most nimble
of elves got up on the wrong side of the
bed and may not go first in combat
important fact initiative is dynamic
that means if initiative scores changed
during combat the order in which turns
are taken will change accordingly if
every character had the actions a new
turn will start the turns ending is
shown by an indicator and now you're
ready for action when it's one of your
characters turn you can see the action
radius split into a small lock brightly
highlighted area and a larger darker
area of hexes the bright area indicates
the radius in which a character can move
in
still perform an action like attacking
or using an object the larger one
indicates the maximum movement range how
fire action radius actually is is
determined by a character's speed value
by the way a character can hold the
action and take the turn at the end of
an initiative face attack Parry and
dodge one of the core actions during
combat is big surprise
attacking after all we're not here for
tea and biscuits if you move the cursor
over an attackable enemy your head
chance will be displayed clicking now
would execute an attack if your
character's not a weapon range they will
automatically close in on the enemy in
most cases an opponent won't just stand
there and wait to get a dwarf next to
the Hat an important aspect of the
blackguards combat system is also to
parry
with the parry a defender completely
avoids the attack to parry it's
obligatory to hold a weapon in your hand
that's why some creatures without
weapons can't parry at all
pairing means of the attackers attack
value is compared to the defenders parry
value if they're equal
the attackers hit chance is 60% every
point difference means a probability
shift of 5% in the corresponding
direction the special thing about
pairing is each character can only parry
once per turn it's a solid tactic to
make an opponent use up their parry
before you get out of the big guns to
hit them hard whether a character can
still parry in the current turn is
indicated in a mouse over text blue
means the parry action is still
available if it's highlighted red the
parry action is already spent also an
important fact you can only parry merely
a text if you want to parry a ranged
attack you need a shield equipped in
your offhand
if your parry action is spanned or your
character simply isn't able to parry
dodging an incoming blows the last
resort a successful dodge is usually
much less likely than a parry for your
roles that means that the attack value
is now compared to the dodge value other
than that dr. Berg is pretty similar to
Perry performing a Dodge happens on
demand and without a limit pattern keep
in mind though that each subsequent
dodge after the first and within the
same turn will have a -2 modifier if a
character attacks there is a 5% chance
of a critical hit the crate always
connects damage is doubled and it also
automatically inflicts a wound
you can also glitch there's a 5% chance
that your character will miss no matter
how bad an enemy's defense might be
there's only one exception if an
opponent is prone for example through a
knockdown effect an attack will always
succeed your character can do more than
just jab or clobber things the most
basic way possible and for that there
are special abilities adding a little
bad leanness to your attacks a deathblow
for example inflicts severe wounds using
a special attack often brings along a
penalty to attack Rhodes thus using a
special attack is somewhat riskier but
also rewarding to use them however a
character needs to a learn the special
ability and B has to equip a weapon able
to perform the special attack
damage wounds and more ways to die even
at high connects this of course also
damage inflicted how many of your
enemies precious vitality points bleed
away largely depends on your character's
weapon their strength and the opponent's
arm basically the attacker does a damage
role according to the weapon stats let's
say add these six plus two resulting in
a damage range between three and eight
after that add in a character's strength
bonus depending on the weapon used a
dagger has a hard time benefiting from
raw strength compared to a heavy
slashing weapon after that armor rating
comes into effect each armor provides
damage mitigation and form of a
resistance rating that's how much
percent of damage are subtracted armor
sets also provide a flat armor value
that directly mitigates damage by its
value apart from direct damage
inflicting wounds is also a good way to
weaken your foes wounds can be caused by
chance if the enough damage is caused or
they can be inflicted by the use of
certain special abilities a character
can stack up to three wounds the only
protection against wounds is the
willpower talent or treating wounds with
bandages or powerful healing magic there
are also other ways to buff or debuff a
character for example by being poisoned
status effects are indicated by blue or
red errors on a character's portrait
hovering the cursor over them will show
more details special combat styles
ranged weapons have a few special
features the most obvious is perhaps
that you gain range range weapons need
ammunition and they reach as far as your
character's line-of-sight attacking with
a ranged weapon is connected to the
ranged combat value and as said earlier
a ranged attack can only be parried with
a shield
however the effective range depends on
the actual weapon usually each weapon
has a minimum and maximum reach anything
above or below these parameters will
result in a penalty to the ranged attack
role like a melee weapon a ranged weapon
can't exceed hit chance of 90 percent if
the target isn't prone in regards of
defense you cannot parry while using a
range
who needs a shield go for dual wield
some of the bolder individuals seem to
think along those lines and prefer to
swing a one-handed weapon in each hand
keep in mind that you're offering is
much less likely to hit if you do not
have the special ability dual weird
dear weird attacks are only executed
with an ability using two weapons this
is basically the same as normal melee
combat only that your character now has
to attack values there's still only one
to hit role you either hit or miss with
both weapons and even a dual wielding
character can only parry once each time
and then there's magic magic does not
quite behave like your good old combat
with steel and arrow you can't dodge or
parry a spell and magic companies as
well as simply succeeds or fails that
again depends on a character's base
values wrath of the elements for example
is linked to charisma Constitution and
courage all these attributes are checked
with the dice roll with a d20 if all
roads are equal or lower than the
attribute value the spell goes off if
not despair talent value can compensate
bad guys results and if that's not
sufficient the spell will fizzle it
doesn't consume aspera points if it fits
though how is one supposed to
concentrate around here in case of a
success aspirin points are spent
accordingly depending on the level of
the spell there are also modifiers that
are applied to the talents value a
simple in effect CS bold of flame and
level one gets a bonus of +2 but the
same spell at level 4 the most powerful
version of the igni factious that has an
area of effect is cast with a negative
modifier of minus 8 to defend against
magic there is magic resistance that
contacts for example d buffs like vessel
when casting such as well the resistance
to magic is directly subtracted from the
sports talent value so if your core
professor has a value of 8 in your
targeted resistance to magic of 5 you
only have 3 points left to compensate if
the dice don't like you
using your environment and talent tests
a huge factor in blackguards battles is
the environment itself very often you'll
encounter elements that work in your
character's favor or in worst case to
their disadvantage a simple example for
such environmental elements are crates
your characters can top of them block
paths or even crush enemies underneath
them interactive elements are usable by
simply clicking them this spends the
characters action for the current turn
there are also elements on the
battlefield you cannot use directly but
that can benefit you anyway if you know
how an ordinary waterway can turn into a
hazardous trap as characters pass the
water there's a chance to slip if they
don't succeed in a body control test
this test works just as fair casting
described above only with corresponding
attributes for body control this is also
true for the talent perception
perception hubs detecting hazardous
hidden elements from flammable swamp gas
- deadly machinery blackguards offers
many ways to turn your environment into
ill weapon the better groans layout
itself also offers plenty room for
tactics you can block choke points in a
cave to your advantage for example with
good positioning you can slay one enemy
after another without breaking a sweat
so keep your eyes open who knows what
minor Terran feature may save your bacon
gear you can't go into a fight
completely naked well technically you
could but we don't recommend that
so in closure of this episode we'll give
you some advice regarding your equipment
weapons have aside from their obligatory
damage stats also other modifiers that
influence attack parry and initiative
they're also connected to a weapon
talent and each weapon also has
restrictions in terms of special
abilities you can perform with it your
characters can swap between up to three
weapon sets swapping weapons however
spends a turns
action armors are designed to prevent
damage they all have armor specific
resistance ratings and most armors are
part of a set if your character wears a
complete matching set the armor will
provide a flat damage mitigation bonus
and
come brains is significantly reduced
speaking of which encumbrance is an
armor stat indicating how restraining or
heavy the armor one is encumbrance
applies negative modifier to attack
parry dodge and initiative so don't wear
too heavy armor or spent adventure
points on these special ability armor
used also keep in mind that too many
items carried around could result in an
encumbrance penalty for the whole party
another important part of your gear up
belts as they hold many useful items a
character can carry into battle good
belts can hold up to four items third
slots are for healing and astral potions
throwing weapons poisons and traps
without a belt you can't use them in
combat
did you win an especially tricky battle
by lateral thinking or did you use other
even dirty tricks to make your party's
life easier well tell us right here or
in the forums or visit us on Facebook
our forums and of course the official
Black Arts homepage there you can find
the most recent news regarding black
arts and day Dalek if you want to read
the content of this video again there's
also a text guide you still didn't join
the adventure then off you go and
download your digital version at steam
or car comm we hope you're now ready to
take on any battle in event area
you